if I if I were in a seat I'd be on the
edge of it all right here we go
[Music]
you are watching yet another episode of
mr. wonderful I'm not him I'm just a
guest I might grow your questions we
answer them it's gonna be great
hi my name is Monty I'm 22 I'm a big fan
of both Kevin and Mike my question is
about young people and the perception of
success it seems like for people of my
generation if you are a hard worker and
you are interested in doing great things
in life it's almost the default path for
you to go to university get really good
grades and everybody wants to be a
professor everybody wants to be a doctor
everybody wants to be an investment
banker and it seems like simply getting
a well-paid job in the trades investing
your money running your own business
these things are swept under the rug and
are seen as being less prestigious and
obviously that's a big misconception how
can we address this misconception
amongst youth and what do you think are
the best methods to reach out to young
people this message that following the
path laid out for you is not necessarily
going to be the right path for everybody
thank you Mike that's a big question and
he's got multiple levels in there
this idea of prestige you know I've
always been intrigued with that that you
take a path and take a history degree
instead of becoming a plumber sounds
like a pretty stupid thing prestige what
is that let's trying to find that issue
well let's start with his name Monti
first thing I heard was Monty Hall let's
make a deal all right and you're the man
who makes deals and what he's talking
about fundamentally is a is a
proposition and it's a transactional
proposition that will lead to some level
of prestige the answers is how much so
what we've been told for the last 45
years is that the best path for the most
people happens to be the most expensive
path but if you never get a college
degree does that make you a lesser
person well depends who you ask a lot of
people would say yeah what we did with
college was we gave it a PR push and it
needed one back in the 60s and 70s but
we pushed
at the expense of all other forms of
education so College became a cautionary
tale if you don't get the four-year
degree then you're gonna wind up turning
a wrench or being a welder or some such
vocational consolation prize we set the
table long we jacked with the very
definition of prestige and thereby made
it impossible for anyone who didn't have
a degree or at least very very difficult
to compete for that prestige on a level
playing field look I think my view of
this and I've been trying to get lots of
people in their 20s to think it this way
the hardest job in the world is to break
free from the family that gave you a
cocoon and helped launch you sure and
then you finish whatever level of
education you get that could be high
school but at some point you're on your
own and you've got to go to work you've
got to make a living and then eventually
maybe support a family or a significant
other whatever it is and it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day
whether you're welding a car together or
whether you're teaching in a high school
or whether you're a doctor you still
have the same challenge and I think
great prestige is being someone who can
actually successfully raise a family
that's what I tell people because I
don't really give a [ __ ] what you do as
long as you do it well right so get paid
well well speaking of [ __ ]
I mean Dirty Jobs was an homage to a
willingness to get dirty and the first
season of that show I affirmative Lee
looked for sewage workers sewer
inspectors I look for septic tank
cleaners who who became good at doing
something most people didn't want to do
and then found a way to love it right so
for me it's always the the prestige
thing is fundamentally backwards we tell
kids today the way to be happy is to
first of all correctly identify that
which will make you happy then borrow
whatever money it takes to get happy
then get your magic ticket then punch
the clock then pay your dues and then
finally because I like happy I like that
theme the idea that you can find a
career where you actually want to get up
in the morning and do it is a dream come
true a lot of people don't get there
they take jobs that really don't make
them happy but
I have to eat so they gotta work I think
the real objective here in answering
Monty's question circling back to what
he's asking is you know if you really
think being a doctor or getting you know
post-secondary education is going to
make you a better person and make you
more employable you should do it but the
beef I have with everybody that thinks
that way is remember you're gonna get
yourself 60 to 80 thousand dollars in
debt so you better do something where
you can actually get a job and what are
those things well I think there's the
top three or engineering engineering and
engineering sure but engineering is a
perfect example of a job that's both
blue and white collar there are so many
facets of it and it doesn't feed
it doesn't fit neatly into one vertical
but it's so wonderful because it doesn't
matter where on that spectrum you are
most engineers get employed which is the
goal sure cuz you don't spend four years
doing it and you're going to accrue debt
as you mentioned yeah yeah it's a 60 70
grand a person that's a personal tragedy
but add it up it's one point six
trillion right now and we hold the note
on that yeah you know well maybe not up
there in Canada but you know down here
and oh it's worse up there
it's basically education it's free up
there but you're paying for it as a tax
payer how secretely not nothing is free
exactly but my point is if you're gonna
spend four years you're burning your own
time that's your own equity right don't
waste it
but any months you have a good question
there but I think my idea is find what
makes you happy I like that but you get
paid because you're not getting paid
you're not gonna eat or find what pays
the bills and then figure out a way to
be happy doing it the people on Dirty
Jobs didn't follow their passion but
they were passionate about what they did
that's what struck me which is it was
just back nothing dirty about making
dough that's what I say I think a lot of
people say but but the way you say it
Kevin it just sounds too damn credible I
think we nailed Marty's question hit us
with another one thank you for answering
my question today my question is what
would you do or what you advise someone
to do if they're spreading themselves
thin with too many projects or ideas
I've currently am working for
the hours at my job I'm getting ready
step into my dad's business that's
online I'm trying to run my own business
which isn't taking off very well and if
I fall back on one or the other and they
seem to fail I've got a third plan of
running my own restaurant type deal in
the works between that and trying to
remodel my house that I've had for a
year and I'm not even living and yet
what would you advise for someone who's
trying to juggle too many things at once
and how to make it work thank you okay
that's too crazy there's too much stuff
going on there well he's shooting with a
shotgun
it needs a rifle yeah it's brutal I you
know my advice to him Mike is pick the
top three on the hit parade and even
that's almost too much but running a
restaurant is and I did that once that
is an 18 hour a day job and so I'd kill
that thing like that is that is so hard
to make money and really as a time
killer I like the idea of the leverage
of maybe taking over his dad's online
business because it's probably working
and then figuring out a way to get more
customers and a lower cost I like a
little focus what do you think well he's
got to figure out what he wants to be I
think I mean for me I figure there are
two basic types of people when it comes
to getting something done there those
who can truly multitask and there are
those who are many not many yet and that
was my point multitasking gets all the
glamour and people talk about living in
a nonlinear world and the necessity of
being able to juggle and spin the plates
and all the metaphors I'm a slave to
chronology the number four only makes
sense to me when it comes after three
and precedes five I do one thing and I
go to the next thing and then I builds
as best I can on that thing but I don't
know how people I mean I know how they
do it I can't do it but to have these
different branches coming off of the
same tree and tending to them all
contemporaneously it's it's it's out of
my pay grade my take is you get a core
gig that you know you're good at and is
your
baseline it's the thing you feed and
maintain and make sure it works you try
and make it more efficient whatever that
is and then if you're an entrepreneur
and you want to explore something and
you can use an example like an Elon Musk
who's a uber entrepreneur sure Tesla
probably eats up 60% 70% of his week but
he's also in the battery business and
he's shooting stuff into space I get all
that
but the one that he cares about the most
is the one that's having the biggest
challenges of growth which is Tesla
right now I know this because it's my
son's an intern for him and he's focused
yeah he hasn't waste his time he comes
in he works like hell and I think
everybody should find their Tesla make
sure that they're staying focused on
that and then if you want to shoot
rockets into space or make batteries or
do something else that's cool but unless
you're a multitasker a proven one I
think getting one thing right proves
that you can do it is very important and
what about once you get the one thing
right then you can be duplicative by
simply taking that that thing like I was
fired three times from QVC back in back
in 1990 is my first job in TV and I
learned some lessons there and those
lessons translated into dirty jobs
twelve years later that show wound up in
200 countries since dirty jobs I've done
somebody's got to do it returning the
favor and the way I heard it it's all
the same basic show that all require me
to apply the same basic lessons that I
learned once upon a time so if you
glanced at my resume for what it is you
see a bunch of stuff that looks
disparate in fact I just changed the
name of the show every five or six years
I keep doing the same thing it's great
advice and I am you know I think
successful entrepreneurs have that
common element because I worked for
three months once making cat food and
the guy who taught me how to do it was
Dutch and he said all cat food is is
either see if it's a pan tuna with
different flavors in it or it's beef
lips and renderings of you know chicken
heads boiled down to a broth and then
flavor added to it
and the reason I like that story is
decades later when I was a co-founder of
the learning company it's math and
reading skills to sell consumer software
and we went to the same model of cat
food we had one corage and then we just
add another character to it so you're
reading with rena rabbit or carmen
sandiego or any of the titles we did
they were just taking the same paste and
adding and adding right and I like I
like those analogies once you understand
what you're doing and you leverage it I
think there's a lesson for everybody in
that actually well and it goes to
identity too like how do you see
yourself in your chosen field how do you
see yourself and your vertical you know
for me the thing because I felt a lot
like that guy once upon a time I just
felt scattered like just spread way too
thin you can in his in his voice you
could hear his desperation and the
indecision yeah I don't think he knows
who he is so right up until 2002
I made a decent living impersonating a
host that was my stock and trade I could
hell you don't want to hear that like I
guess I could hit my mark I could say my
line and and I and I got paid for it but
on dirty jobs I learned how to be a
guest and I still hosted shows but I did
it through a kind of the Greeks would
call it a parapet eeeh right yeah and
edgar Issa so I said wait a second what
if I'm still a host in the credits but
what if I act like a guest like an
avatar or or a cipher and let somebody
else be the X well if you're honest
about it and because I've learned over
time people can smell [ __ ] a mile
away they're more so today than ever
ever especially kids
yeah and they get it and so the you know
if you're if you're trying to be
something you're not it's not gonna work
but getting back to this guy I think our
collective advice is pick one thing and
make it happen yeah and then prove you
can do that and once you've got that
humming and efficiently working and
you've nailed it
then add to your dilemma as I like to
say do something else but the one core
there I heard was the dad's business my
bed is that's working he could get
focused on that maybe enhance it
eventually take it over
that's what
families are for maybe that works but
interesting question raised a lot of
issues we discussed it just because you
can do something doesn't mean you should
right particularly if it makes no money
alright next on the hit parade
I miss your wonderful principal thank
you for having this opportunity for all
of us to ask questions and learn from
somebody successful as you are I have
recently become a director of operation
for a business and I have never had a
position of this scale before and I
really need some feedback from you to
help me become a better leader to become
somebody that has enough empathy and
understanding for people but somehow has
enough toughness to be able to put the
business first
I find myself struggling between being
humane and being a leader and I really
would want to find that balance and I
would appreciate your input and I thank
you very much I like that question this
is a question about leadership and I'm
gonna take a stab at it then I want to
hear your your view of this so Jazmin is
trying to figure out how to manage
people and that is tough there's no
question there is no one perfect way
part of its your personality part of its
how people respect or don't respect you
my take of it and what I've learned
works for me because I've worked with a
lot of teams I've been both a leader and
an operator and an employee and you name
it yes you sit down with your team one
at a time you know go out for a coffee
whatever say look what can you do in the
next three months for me
what can we agree on as a goal that you
buy into that right here and now what is
it going to be you're gonna do X
whatever it is and we shake hands on
this thing and I get out of your way I'm
not gonna be all over you for the next
three months you're either gonna make it
or you're not so don't sell me something
you can't deliver make sure as we go
through this little meeting then you can
deliver on this I know you might try and
sandbag me that's okay too
but I just want to know what are you
committing to now I'm gonna write it
down and we're gonna meet up again in 90
days and you're either how good have
made it or not yeah I found that works
Jazmin I think you're gonna be fine
I think she's gonna be fine because she
used the magic word and her question and
the magic word is empathy you don't hear
it much today your sympathy and of
course you hear leadership and you hear
authenticity right there are a lot of
buzzwords but empathy like real empathy
is impossible to fake and the only way
your people will empathize with you in
my view is if they see you doing their
job or at least trying to and that
that's all I do that's all my brand is I
get if I did one smart thing looking
back it was figuring out how to get paid
to try not succeed but try not easy to
see it all the time it's impossible but
it's easy to try all of the time and so
if you want someone's respect in my
opinion then the best thing you can do
for them is to show an interest in the
job you hired them to do let them see
you trying to do that that's when real
empathy goes back and forth and I you
know I look at people differently who
who I've seen tried to do my job and I
think vice versa so I mean it's such a
fluid marketplace today and work looks
different than it used to you know looks
different I found the biggest impediment
to getting people to do great work is
you're in their face too much you over
manage them you don't let them find
other ways and pass you never thought of
so you know Jasmine sets up a goal for
some one of our team members and says
look go make it happen
stand back let them do their thing and
you'll find out what they're good and
not good at and look if they
consistently can't deliver well you got
to take them up behind the bar and you
know what has to happen but yeah but
generally speaking people will find
their own ways to get things done if
they believe it's a fair deal that
you've let the buy into something and
you both agreed they're going to do it
but doesn't I mean that
if you're in an outcome-based
environment often what work is right
except when you sit down with the
handbook and the protocols and there are
many institutions today that still say
look this is this isn't the result we
need they're saying this is how we need
you to behave in order to get the result
we want I'm not a fan of that I find it
creates a lot of inefficiency sure I'd
rather have a maverick renegade get
something done without looking at the
rulebook because at the end getting the
results of what I covet particularly as
an investor so you know most of my
companies are small the average is 26
people in size yeah I don't care how
they do it just get it done and at that
size maybe that's what matters at most
you're talking about big institutions
that is a big problem when you're a
renegade and you piss everybody off even
if you're successful they don't like you
no but on the other hand getting stuff
done is always rewarded in every culture
in every business you have to balance it
I don't see a lot of people getting
whacked that gets stuff done unless
they've really broken the rules and in
these days that involves a lot of stuff
that didn't use to matter in the 60s but
now there's issues but that's a great
question I'm glad she asked it I think
we gave her some good advice look I
don't want to overstate it but maybe the
best advice ever really yeah
both you and micro have partially
achieved your success through show
business so what can you say to convince
the youth of today that show business
YouTube fame movie fame any kind of fame
isn't the only answer what can you say
to convince them that there's more than
just being famous Heather asks a really
great question because I have a new
perspective on Fame and I'll tell you a
great story when Shark Tank first
started nobody watched it there was a
cat in the dog watching it for three
years ago canceled three years in a row
and every year there be a new executive
at ABC network that said outs get
another chance and then the fourth year
for reasons nobody really understands
it goes from zero to ten million I was
watching it you know stuff happens and
that's one of the first time ever I was
I went into a washroom in Boston Logan
Airport and no one had ever recognized
me before anything and I'm doing my
business in the urinal and the guy keeps
looking over at me after like three
gazes he says are you that guy on Shark
Tank I said wow somebody's watching
Shark Tank that's what I was thinking
yeah
and he says I say yeah I'm that guy in
Shark Tank and he says you're an [ __ ]
and he gives me this hour yeah this this
diatribe about how I was unfair to
somebody or what they deal was too rich
or whatever and my wife and my daughter
Savannah are waiting outside for me and
he storms out and I didn't know this
till later but he says to my wife hey
that [ __ ] Kevin O'Leary's in the
men's room and she says I know but that
to me was the beginning of the journey
of entrepreneurship in terms of Fame
because the the guy that was running the
network at that time said to me a year
later
how are you loving this this this
celebrity
tell me the truth how are you really
loving it and there is downside to it
I've always thought the best part of it
was for me is I can use this fame to
help somebody acquire customers at their
business at a lower cost which is all I
do now sure I got 50 companies I spend
most of my day
using my celebrity to help them get into
Walmart get into Target get into Best
Buy are beyond because I can call the
CEO and they return my call which is
great yeah that's the benefit of it and
there's some downside to it too so
Heather I mean yeah everybody wants to
be famous but nobody quite knows how to
do it there is no playbook and I think
that's a good thing because Fame isn't
supposed to be a goal it's supposed to
be a symptom it comes from it comes from
being respected or from doing a good job
and it's easy to confuse fame with
celebrity I talked to your kid about why
do you want to be
why do you want people to know you
because I can make a long list of people
I know who I don't respect would you
rather be well-known and not respected
we're simply known because you did
something like maybe embarrass yourself
on American Idol
we're on Shark Tank maybe you're famous
because you went on Shark Tank and all
the Sharks laughed at you and now the
whole country knows who you are you
don't really want that right you don't
really want Fame what you really want
I bet is something like self-respect so
Heather I'm going to tell you something
you have to tell your child because
they're old enough to understand this in
life it's extremely difficult to try and
set goals on an attribute you can't
control you can't control Fame you can't
make yourself famous it's a derivative
of something you did or achieved or that
you could control that went well and so
if you really want to set up your child
for for a I'm gonna say a good life make
sure they don't start working out things
they can never achieve because they
can't control them and that would be
Fame so I and the thing about famous it
shines the light on some and sets the
others free and there's nothing you can
do about it I would tell that to your
child do not set them up saying you're
gonna be famous no matter what happens
because that just isn't true but you can
have a great life achieving the things
and the goals that you can actually
control hey mr. wonderful I'm from Paris
so excuse me for my accent I heard you
saying that you should be ruthless in
business also Mark Cuban say that it's
like a sport but it's 24/7 competition
so I know that I am not that competitive
and I care about others feeling also I
don't I don't like to make people not
love me so I never experience how my
personality would be in the business
world and entering an entrepreneurship
because I'm just starting this path so
my question is this
I should change my personality in order
to succeed in the business world
Shawn bad news you can't change a
personality you can try but people will
smell the [ __ ] a mile away you are
what you are and the truth is business
is competitive get over it it's it's a
form of war in some ways and you will
never ever ever get everybody to like
you ever and if you spend your time
worrying about that you will fail for
sure you can't care about what people
think as long as you think you're doing
the right thing they'll end up
respecting you they may not like you
that's certainly my situation I don't
care if you like me I care that you
respect me and that I am being honest
with you about what I expect you to do
for me if you're working for me or if
I'm investing in you if you want to be
an entrepreneur you got to get up in the
morning understanding there's some guy
in Mumbai or Shanghai or somewhere in
China that wants to kick your ass and
it's coming for you 24/7
because it's true but if you can deal
with all that you'll be okay is a great
question it is a great question and
listening to you talk about it it really
it goes back to authenticity right your
people like you because they don't like
you there's truth you've been very
consistent with your brand and your
persona this guy sounds he sounds like a
sweetheart
he sounds he sounds a you know very
empathetic he C he sounds like probably
who he is that doesn't mean you can't
function in the deep end of the pool
that doesn't mean you can't compete
it just means you shouldn't pretend to
be somebody you aren't because look in
my business authenticity is authenticity
is for sale everywhere but especially in
my business you said it before people
can smell a fake I think they can smell
it in the boardroom just as easily as
they can smell it in the sewer yeah so
John you you can't change your
personality but you can change the rules
of the game you choose to play in my
opinion you know I I my business model
for
14 years was based on imitating hosts
and in this business you can get away
with it and I was pretty good at it
and I I wasn't looking for a hit show I
was looking to take my retirement in
early installments so that I could work
a month here take a month off a month
there well in the entertainment business
you can do that and I figured out how to
do that and it worked for a long time
and then one day I was 42 and I I didn't
have a lot of meaning and what I was
doing so I I decided to reinvent myself
to a certain degree and become more of a
host or more of a guest and less of a
host really and and that's when I wound
up becoming the person I actually am
that's just a long way of saying again
you can't change who you are
it took me 14 15 years to figure out how
is the best advice you could give
anybody because if if you start a career
or a path where you think you can morph
yourself into something else and be
honest about it it just isn't gonna
happen
no and all the way through everybody
around you is gonna just smell it and
know you're just being who you're not
and if you look at the people who get
all the press today it's not the people
who really cut through I mean Elon Musk
say what you want about him you he's a
known entity now the he's a yeah he's a
brand he is a reflection of his identity
you know he knows exactly who he is and
John you can be I think exactly who you
are
and a complete failure you can also be
exactly who you are and be a wild
success but I like the fact that he
wants to take a shot at it and I think
John go good like give it a shot
Mike's sitting right in front of me is
this book
Hansa book it's very attractive I like
the guy in the front micro the way I
heard it right here what's this about
well I started writing a podcast about
three years ago and the style of Paul
Harvey you remember the rest of the
story of course so short biographical
mysteries about famous people and you
get to figure out who I'm talking about
as I write anyway the podcast turned
into a thing 130 million downloads and a
publisher that is a thing it's a thing
and the publisher said you should put 50
of him together we'll put up hardcover
on it it'll be a book so you extracted
the very best of the podcast put it I
was gonna do and I showed it to my
mother she said oh Michael what an
amazingly lazy way to publish a book so
so I said well what do you suggest she's
being honest she's honest and my mom's a
best-selling author you know and so I
listened to her and she said I what do
you want me to do she said why don't you
write a memoir of sorts about why you
chose to write about these famous people
you've never met so and what you know
about it or what you or is there
something in your own life that rhymes
with something in theirs so basically
the way I heard it started as a
collection of my favorite podcast
stories it became a memoir that is
interrupted every other chapter by a
true --is-- story of a famous person who
I've never met
that's cool all right look everybody I
own asked mr. wonderful check this out
this is good advice from a guy that
knows what he's doing I like that you
know books are tough they're like
they're really I've done three of them
myself and I know it's like giving birth
if you it's not easy everybody should
write a book and everybody should wait
tables yeah yeah because you do you you
don't mean to but you wind up putting
yourself on the couch I have a lot of
respect for anybody that gets it done
because I know how hard this okay check
it out hey mr. wonderful this is sue J
I'm 39 years old I invested in three
entrepreneurship ventures mostly a lot
of my personal time and energy into it a
little bit of my personal money in one
of them although all three did not cut
it how does one reset and rebound after
such failures especially when such
failures get tagged on to your resume
and it's hard to find new investors does
that mean I'm pretty much a dead
cockroach
thanks well I'll start answering that
question this way I would personally
rather invest someone who has felt the
sting of failure and is motivated by the
fear of failing a fourth time then
someone who thinks they can never fail
because it will visit everybody it just
does I've had plenty of failures
sometimes it's luck Mike sometimes it's
just being in the wrong place at the
wrong time three times in a row and the
fourth is the one that's going to work
I'd invest in that guy sure I think he
probably has learned something from his
mistakes and that sometimes what they
are but failure I mean it is just part
of everybody's life and there's many
ways to fail and it's really easy to
fail and very hard to succeed if you
learn something from your failure it's
not a failure
the only real real failure of course is
the is the failure it's a try right and
and again that was that's dirty jobs 101
for me you know once I once I really let
go of my ego right fourteen fifteen
years in the business you get used to
looking a certain way and you acting
like you know more than you look dirty
jobs required me to fail day after day I
was an apprentice it was I was ground
hogs day for me in a sewer every day I'm
showing up on a new job site knowing
nothing and not only am I
really forced to learn everything I can
on that day I have to do it on camera
I'm getting the pie in the face over and
over once I realized that that in fact
was was a kind of blessing my my career
changed incredibly you know I think the
whole issue of failure people are so
scared of it but it visits everybody
that's what I tell them and I teach this
stuff I try and teach it I say it's
going to happen I guarantee you and it's
gonna be miserable when it happens and
even worse if it's your own money yeah
which happens a lot but at the end of
the day you should know with certainty
that everybody around you that's
successful has already tasted that sting
there isn't a single entrepreneur I've
met that's been successful that can't
list a whole bunch of disasters they
were involved in and is there anything
more breathtakingly dull than somebody
who was born into a fabulous trust and
who never really failed at anything yeah
I mean I I I look at it and say if
you're telling me all you've had in your
life is success I know you're lying to
me that's what I know because it just
doesn't work that way that's just the
nature of entrepreneurship
okay so Sanjay let me tell you something
if I worried about what people thought
about me as I was going through my
journey as an entrepreneur operator I
would have never done anything you just
can't let that get in your way you got
enough problems just running a business
to worry about oh I wonder what they
think about me you should be saying
yourself who gives a [ __ ] I'll get this
thing done and people respect me for the
way I did it that's it that's the end of
the day and not everybody will be your
friend or like you as a result you know
it's tough but that's just the way it is
Sanjay yeah you're right I don't have a
lot of experience with investors but I
have a lot of experience in trying to
get people to like me and what I've
learned is that you can't ignore them
you actually work for them the customer
is your boss but the minute they think
you're trying to win their favor instead
of being who you are they will eat you
they will eat you alive right statue out
and and then just laugh about it I see
this on Facebook every day I fight with
people on Facebook aye-aye-aye welcome
negative comments because I engage with
them respectfully and I argue from the
middle and I try and get them to change
their mind but I but I don't beg them to
the minute
does anything stink more than
desperation they can smell it on you
it's it's it's interesting too you know
to let people that criticize you get to
you that is a that's a horrible weakness
you have to get callus you have to
understand you can't please everybody
and they'll be attacking you all the
time but I had a great mentor he's dead
now he used to be a hockey coach and
Jerry Patterson was his name and he said
you got to shut out the noise if to set
the goal every day focus on that and
everything else is irrelevant he was a
great coach that way he he really was
very good and I've always remembered
that I always remember Jerry sitting on
my shoulders saying don't worry about it
doesn't matter it's irrelevant your fans
are your fans because they don't believe
that you're desperate to have them as
fans you gave them a chance to like you
or not like you and your whatever they
don't yeah so what do you do when
something terrible happens in your life
and it will happen in life poopoo
happens it just does it happens to
everybody and you know I can think about
when I was young my dad died when he was
37 years old I was you know eight that's
not supposed to happen that's and it was
very really had a huge impact on my
brother and I was two years younger than
me but I remember thinking through that
saying I can't control that there's
nothing I can do about it I've got to
live with it now and just even at that
young age realize Wow life's tough and
then then you die like think about that
and if you want to be miserable thinking
that way that's how you'll be but you've
got to realize that everybody deals with
it you are not alone and there's a
people around you love you and want to
support you but I guarantee you
everybody that's listening to the answer
that something horrific will happen to
you in your lifetime and you'll have to
take the punch and
up and just drive on see you would never
think of it wouldn't like this but I
swear they're the parallels between
Dirty Jobs and shark tank are amazing
using the platform of television to
promote something that but the she runs
but people think Dirty Jobs was a love
letter to blue-collar work it was
actually a love letter to
entrepreneurship I'm great
forty of the people we featured on there
of the three hundred we're
multimillionaires nobody knew it because
they were covered in crime it's great
that it's celebrated work it didn't
matter if you had a PhD that had nothing
to do with it no not at all but what you
had to be able to do is pivot I remember
a guy named Matt Freud in a New Canaan
Connecticut at a dairy farm going down
the just circling the very tough
business the milk costs everything cause
of operating this guy was heating his
entire farm with cow [ __ ] right and that
was smart and then he realized that the
petunias in his garden were growing like
crazy because he was putting them he
called him cow pots just these molded
extruded hardened pots made of cow crap
and you put the flour in there and went
it biodegrades everything well I heard
about that
I took the crew there and we looked at
the dairy farmer who realized his cows
crap was more valuable than its milk
told that story he's in Walmart three
months later
selling cow pots so yeah on the one hand
we crawled through sewers look you could
have any changed it to poop pots
actually that that's that's the pivoting
idea you know it's it's a a lot of
entrepreneurs have shown off at shark
tank with one ID we've it's been wrong
on so long that we have them coming back
saying that last idea I had just kidding
it didn't work yeah there's my new idea
and we bring them back well what do you
tell 20-year olds who are like entering
the market today and they have their
idea their their precious idea or maybe
they don't maybe they just have ambition
how do you counsel them to to find the
right balance that's going to lead to
something that looks like success I say
to them go get some sales
go sell some of this to somebody right
prove to me that not your mother or your
aunt or your father sell it to somebody
you don't know and get a hundred people
to buy it and then listen to what they
have to say show me that you can
actually sell it that is the beginning
of a wild journey for most people
because they realize how hard it is but
also when they start to get traction
they know it's working and they start to
modify that's the biggest thing for me
are these young entrepreneurs sometimes
they're 18 and they come in and they've
already sold two million dollars worth
of something I don't mean a Kickstarter
campaign
I mean they've run around their
neighborhood and sold it collected the
money and collected the money and
actually manufactured it and built it I
know kids like that are gonna make it
because they know how tough it is
entrepreneurship is a [ __ ] it's really
hard I don't have to tell you that and
the ones that get it realized it's a
it's a 25 hour a day job and it changes
your life and it's not always to the
best for people but if it works here we
are talking about it and the road
traveled and how interesting it was and
I think it's still the road ahead
[Music]
hello I'm micro do you suffer from a
curious mind with a short attention span
are you tired of three-hour podcasts
that go on and on and on I can help
listeners of the way I heard it report
heightened intelligence satisfied
curiosity and sudden bursts of laughter
if your podcast lasts longer than two
hours see a doctor then spend ten
minutes with micro and watch what
happens in other words if you like me
ten minutes is all you need okay so I'm
working on a new track I call it a
six-string scrub I recorded the bass
track back on October you know the way
things go today is the technology is so
advanced you know I've got this little
spire recording system that picked up
the Berkeley auction and I could take it
anywhere grab a mic cable I leave some
guitars at various hotels that I stay at
in New York in LA and and just to mess
around you know you can basically what
all you need is a room with good tone so
you know I record it right up right off
the amp
when I use my 61 strat to lay down the
bass track which I consider Stradivarius
if the guitar just beautiful but now I
want something really bright on the
acoustic side so I'm using this Hussam
Dalton which I picked up a couple of
years ago I went in to buy a Marten and
I fell in love with this house and
Dalton and it's just such a bright
instrument I thought it'd be great for
laying down some acoustic lead on top of
this electric kind of shuffle it's had a
bluesy kind of a jazzy Bob you'll hear
in a second
[Music]
[Music]